Я впевнений що наші спортсмени повинні
бути на олімпіаді підіймати український
прапор а росіяни повинні сидіти вдома з
білорусами і наразі є перспектива Що
росіяни можуть бути на цих змаганнях А
українці будуть сидіти вдома Росія
Готова вкладати величезні величезні
гроші свої в те щоб і підкуповувати
людей в тому числі міжнародними
військами Та ми зараз воюючи країну і
всі це розуміють і це жодного спортсмена
немає бажання
виходити на змагання там і стояти на
одному п'єдесталі зі з представниками
е-е Російської Федерації там або з
Республікою Білорусь У нас вже біля 300
спортсменів які загинули на цій війні
сьогодні говоримо із олімпійським
чемпіоном і народним депутатом від
фракції слуга народу Жаном беленюком
Добрий день Вітаю вас Дякую що
погодилися на розмову хотілось би почати
з гучної теми яку нині обговорюють в
Україні зокрема Постанову Кабміну яка
забороняє українським спортсменам брати
участь у змаганнях у яких представлені
росіяни Як ви відреагували на цю
Постанову взагалі це постанова вона була
достатньо неочікувана Як для мене так і
напевно для спортсменів і цей холдерів
нашої сфери і що саме цікаво що після
оприлюднення цієї постанови
вище керівництво Міністерства воно
ніяким чином не комунікує з приводу що
це означає і до чого це може призвести
тобто які цілі ми переслідуємо подібними
рішеннями ми знаємо як цьому класі
знаходяться зараз багато сімей багато
спортсменів тобто дехто тренується за
кордоном їхня їхні сім'ї живуть за
кордоном тобто вони вже рік там пробули
і якщо вони бачать подібну ситуацію
всередині нашої держави з тим що вони не
можуть зрозуміти яким чином вони зможуть
виступати не зможуть якщо зможуть То
коли це буде ніхто це не комунікує ніхто
це не пояснює Звісно що це буде ну це
по-перше велике демотивуючі фактори
по-друге це буде їх спонукати
замислитись над тим а чому нам не
Перейти за ту країну де вони зараз
перебувають тому що якщо брати
взагалі позицію це якщо брати боротьбу
або інші види спорту українські
спортсменів скрізь поважають скрізь
готові їх взяти в свої Лави тому що в
нас багато видів спорту в яких українці
показують
лідуючі позиції тому ось в цьому я
вбачаю головну небезпеку і
від того що керівництво Міністерства
воно ніяким чином не е-е не комунікує не
розповідає свої Цілі задачі е-е чого
вони хочуть досягти цим і плюс до цього
вони не пояснюють хто з нами якщо це
головна мета залучити І об'єднати якусь
міжнародну коаліцію навколо нас для того
щоб
подібні кроки мали дійсно суттєвий удар
по іміджу міжнародного альпійського
комітету що багато країн потенційно не
будуть брати участь в Олімпійських іграх
або там відбіркових етапах до цих
Олімпійських іграх Ігор то Звісно що ми
повинні знати А хто з нами тому що за
моєю інформацією Ми поки що самі Ось і
тобто щоб це не виглядало просто як
постріл собі в ногу Ви маєте багато
знайомих і друзів в спортивних колах як
реагують українські спортсмени на це
рішення всі питають так а що робити
на мені складно відповісти на це питання
тому що я не знаю
нічого тому що в Міністерство ніяким
чином це не коментує тому в спортсмени
вони в очікуванні
найболючіша історія пов'язана з
спортсменами які зараз тільки починають
свій шлях
міжнародних змаганнях Тобто це молоді
спортсмени і наша якби надія на майбутнє
олімпійські досягнення
чому поясню
тому що
воно по-перше згідно цих рекомендацій
Якщо ми будемо брати от федерацію
міжнародної Федерації боротьби згідні
цих рекомендацій нових від міжнародного
олімпійського комітету
там зараз створюється комісії які будуть
перевіряти чи знаходилися
тічні чи спортсмени в лавах Збройних сил
російської там Федерації або Республіки
Білорусь якщо спортсмени ще які не
досягли повноліття то вони за
замовчуванням не можуть бути в лавах і в
нашій міжнародній Федерації їх вже
буквально
відразу на виконкомі нашої Міжнародної
Федерації допустили до змагань тобто U
15 u-18 вони вже будуть Приймати участь
в наступних там чемпіонатах Європи і
подібних змаганнях Тобто ми розуміємо що
наші спортсмени згідно цієї постанови
Вони не зможуть Приймати участь в цих
змаганнях як гадаєте наскільки
справедливим є таке рішення стосовно
українських спортсменів я не маю тієї
кількості інформації для того щоб я міг
зараз про це говорити з
якоюсь долею
ну коректності певної тому що для того
щоб я на цю тему міг дискутувати мені
треба розуміти позицію нашого МЗС
чого ми цим хочемо домогтися які нас
короткострокові і довгострокові плани
якщо цієї інформації немає тобто ну як я
можу казати там Що там правильно
неправильне це рішення або щось інше
тобто я розумію що зараз заручниках
знаходяться наші спортсмени нас непроста
ситуація Тобто ми зараз воююча країна і
всі це розуміють і це жодного спортсмена
немає бажання
виходити на змагання там і стояти на
одному п'єдесталі зі з представниками
Російської Федерації там або з
Республікою Білорусь і вони про це
відповідно заявляють що в нас немає
такого бажання національно-альпійський
комітет зрештом по суті з міністерством
до спорту тому що нас це один одна
людина представник наразі А вони не
змогли втримати е-е саме ту позицію
міжнародного олімпійського комітету яка
була От і тривала цілий рік і нас
з'явилися нові рекомендації і ми бачимо
що наразі від цих рекомендацій
заручниками є наші спортсмени якщо
після цього Після такого рішення
виходить представник Міністерства і
пояснює спортсменам для чого ми це
робимо
і відповідає на ті питання які
з'являються у представників нашої сфери
то я думаю що це була б найкоректніша і
правильна поведінка зі сторони е-е там
Міністерства і нашої спортивної влади
коли це відбувається Просто так в тем ну
по суті просто викачується наказ і ніхто
нікому нічого не пояснює Ну я я можу
уявити обурення спортсменів я можу і Я
особисто Сам не розумію нічого тому що
мені навіть як представнику по суті
парламенту ніхто не
дає ніякої відповіді врахову те що
українські спортсмени не знають як це
заборона буде реалізовуватися і з якою
метою щоб про це думають у світі Ну мені
складно сказати що думають про це у
світі Ну можливо міжнародні партнери
колеги по спорту чи спостерігали ви вже
якісь реакції я
чітко бачив реакцію міжнародного
альпійського комітету на це вони будуть
допомагати тим спортсменам які приймуть
для себе рішення в супереч
діям влади все ж таки Приймати участь в
змаганнях і вони будуть їм допомагати
так розумію що там буде якась це
фінансова підтримка і Ну чесно кажучи
нюансів Не знаю просто вони декларують
те що вони будуть підтримувати подібні
спортсменів тобто я вбачаю в цьому
намагання вбити клин між спортсменами і
українською спортивною владою для того
щоб показати там Ну вони розцінюють
подібні постанови як
втручання в автономію спорту це
фундаментальний принцип який прописаний
в олімпійській хартії про те що спорт
повинен бути автономним і повинні
держава втрачатися в цю історію тобто
єдиний по суті суб'єкт комунікації від
держави з міжнародними альпійськомити
там це на знання олімпійський комітет і
всі заяви там навіть ті які ми робили на
базі українського парламенту або на
комітеті або там від уряду або навіть
від президента це сприймається
міжнародним олімпійському комітетом як
втручання в їхньому автономію і вони це
неодноразово вказують те що вони
некоректно вчинили по відношенню до нас
Ну ми все це розуміємо
Міжнародний олімпійський комітет ви
щойно сказали сказав що готовий
підтримувати українських спортсменів які
все-таки захочуть взяти участь попри
заборону А яка відповідальність може
бути для таких спортсменів в Україні
по-перше починаючи з морально-етичної
складовою подібних рішень і по-друге так
розумію що я взагалі не дуже чесно
кажучи розумію алгоритм
цього процесу тому що в любому випадку
делегують спортсменів на міжнародні
змагання
офіційні це Федерації тобто які будуть
нести відповідальність і Звісно що
Федерація не візьмуть з себе
відповідальність когось відправити
ризикуючи втратити статус національної
при цьому тобто і по суті ризикуючи
позбавити себе як і фінансування так і
можливості проведення і змагань там і
всередині нашої держави і делегування
спортсменів на міжнародні якісь змагання
Тобто це досить серйозно і ніхто навіть
такий ризик не піде ще рік тому ми
спостерігали як світ бекотує російську
культуру російський спорт та 28 березня
Міжнародний олімпійський комітет дає
зелене світло росіянам на участь у
міжнародних змаганнях під нейтральним
прапором на вашу думку чи буде ще
можливість переломити от це рішення адже
ви Наскільки я розумію воно ще не
остаточне саме щодо олімпіади саме щодо
олімпіади вони принесли його на кінець
липня буде рішення по-перше вони вчинили
достатньо хитро вони якби зняли з себе
всю відповідальність і приклали їх на на
плечі міжнародних Федерації і сказали що
у нас тут від нас нові рекомендації але
кінцеве рішення приймаєте
саме ви представники міжнародної
федерації у вас є власні виконкоми і ви
там безпосередньо і ми бачимо різну
реакцію хтось продовжує дискваліфікацію
хтось ті міжнародні Федерації де
проросійський лоб і достатньо сильне і
настрої то Вони одразу ж і починають
залучати
Федерація міжнародної Федерація
фехтування вона ще До рекомендації нових
допустила працівники Росії та Білорусі
до міжнародних змагань Звісно що треба
не покладаючи рук а працювати над тим
щоб
цієї можливості точніше можливості
долучення до олімпіади випускників Росії
та Білорусі не було але я хочу вам
зазначити що для мене
ось ці нові рекомендації які були місяць
тому озвученні це перший крок для того
щоб долучити представників Росії та
Білорусії до олімпіади тому що я не
вбачаю Ніякої логіки зі сторони
міжнародного альпійського комітету брати
на себе стільки хейту і
Такі репутаційні втрати мати після
подібних рішень для того щоб потім вже
там за рік до олімпіади сказати Окей але
ми не допускаємо росіян та білорусів на
ці змагання я вбачаюся як перший крок
промоніторити яким чином міжнародне
суспільство Буде на це реагувати
і далі вже другим разом приймати
рішення про допущення представників
Росії та Білорусії до самої олімпіади Ну
я бачив в цьому логіку
логіку в тому щоб зараз їм дозволити а
потім заборонити Ну воно якось в моїй
голові не клеїться А на вашу думку чи
достатньо зробила Україна для того щоб
не допустили росіян до змагань
міжнародних Ну ви по суті самі випили на
це питання тому що якщо було б зроблено
достатньо напевно їх би не допустили А
якщо їх допустили очевидно недостатньо А
чи можна ще щось зробити як можна
повпливати на
комітет Міжнародний олімпійський на
Федерації точково та які тепер будуть
ухвалювати рішення самостійно про допуск
або недопуск росіян під нейтральним
прапором Ну я вважаю що основна робота
повинна була торкатися безпосередньо
міжнародного Олімпійського коміте і
національна олімпійський комітет повинен
зробити був все для того щоб
рекомендації не були
дані нові такі які маємо наразі чому
поясню тому що вона ми маємо велику
кількість різноманітних федерацій з
різним впливом
Росії всередині цих федерацій
міжнародних і за і зараз по суті коли
вся відповідальність була перекладена з
міжнародного альпійського комітету з
однієї організації на безліч
різноманітних то ми будемо мати
абсолютно
хаотичний підхід до того як ті чи інші
Федерації вирішують подібне питання
дехто тримається дехто одразу допускає
вони досвідчені бюрократи і підібрати
слова для того щоб пояснити мотивацію
їхніх рішень Вони вміють дуже непогано
ось просто для нас воно точно не є
виправдовуванням подібної ситуації тому
що ми не бачимо не вбачаємо абсолютно
жодної
причини робити подібні речі врач на те
що ситуація абсолютно ніяким чином
земельного року не не змінилася ми про
це заявляли і Росія Так і продовжує
вбивати цивільних українців і руйнувати
спортивними інфраструктурою і в нас вже
біля 300 спортсменів які загинули на цій
війні
у цій розмові ви кілька разів згадали
про російський вплив російських лобістів
про які масштаби цього явища взагалі
йдеться
масштаби впливу так ну достатньо
серйозні Авжеж ми всі розуміємо і знаємо
і бачили наскільки
[музика]
серйозно Росія підходить до
міжнародного спорту до олімпійського
руху вода використовує це як
суттєвий важель пропаганди
своєї Хоча вона постійно декларує про те
що спорт повинен бути поза політикою але
вони
напевно більш за всіх за всіх
використовують спортсменів своїх саме
для просування своєї пропаганди своїх
там наративів і подібних речей ми
неодноразово Бачили там і Путіна який
оточує себе навколо там олімпійцями з
медалями олімпіади ми
бачили історії як вони проводили свої
власні олімпіади які скандали були після
того коли фсб-шники замінювали проби
допінгові спортсменам для того щоб ті
хто був під опером їх не зловили і щоб
вони виграли
цю зимову олімпіаду в Сочі в 14-му році
Тобто ми все це бачили
дивилися і можемо зрозуміти що
Росія готова вкладати величезні
величезні гроші свої в те щоб і
підкуповувати людей які
є там суб'єкт суб'єктами певних
прийняття прийняття певних рішень на
користь Росії і
шантаж і
маніпуляція тобто вони не гребують
абсолютно нічим в в плані впливу на
різні організації в тому числі на Альпі
на міжнародним піском так і на
різноманітній Федерації Дехто з
впливового олігархів очолюють там
османов очолює
очолював зараз Якби вінстровний я думаю
що реально його вплив він залишається
міжнародній Федерації фехтування його
дружина
художня гімнастика
а-а ми знаємо
Дворкович шахи ми знаємо
цей
кремльов бокс тобто і Ну ми ще якщо не
будемо брати там якісь віце-президентів
які дуже часто бувають сірими
кардиналами в різноманітних федераціях
міжнародних коли номінальної
якоїсь там
третьої країни а але реальний вплив має
Росія тобто все це якби ми розуміємо і
ну ніхто не вам не скаже що Росія і для
неї спорт там це пусте місце от я вас
слухаю і одразу думаю про те А якщо
все-таки Україна не відправить
спортсменів на олімпіаду чи не зробимо
ми в цьому випадку краще Росії що ми
фактично до моєї майданчик для
подальшої пропаганди
в межах Олімпійських ігор
гарний слушне питання багато хто
в мене запитує саме
подібним чином але я ж не можу
відповісти на це питання тому що не я
ухвалював подібне рішення і
Ну я сам би хотів би почути відповідь
того ж міністра і на або президента
комітету на це ж питання яка позиція які
перспективи яка ціль
і хто з нами Ведмідь брали участь у
Олімпійських іграх маєте і золоту медалі
срібну Розкажіть будь ласка чи
комунікували ви на змаганнях з росіянами
чи пересікалися в Одесі як вони себе
поводили взагалі Ну я особливо не
комунікувати мій підхід до олімпіади я
як правило взагалі там дуже обмежую коло
людей з якими я контактую перед
змаганнями тобто в мене є тренер в мене
там є там сусід по кімнаті там лікар все
ми особливо не пересікалися і сказати як
вони себе поводять Ну це напевно
індивідуальна історія тому що збірна в
них там достатньо велика я думаю що
більше ніж
[музика]
150 людей тобто Звісно що там бувають
напевно різні представники які за різною
поведінкою А як переконати світ в тому
що росіянам все-таки не місце у
міжнародному спорті ну по-перше
повинна бути серйозна медійна складова
тому що всі ці рішення це в тому числі і
емоція люди коли знаходяться не в
контексті того що проходить всередині
нашої держави вони вони якби розуміють
що вона війна це погано
все Ну вони проти війни це це погано а
коли вони бачать що це таке
безпосередньо і з чим стикаються
українці
і як вони приховуються в
укриттях як кожен день там
вони Сядь під обстрілами як вони
втрачають своїх рідних та близьких і як
гинуть наші солдати які бореться за свою
землю Ось вони не пішли до когось
намагаються захопити чиїсь а просто
відстоюють свій рідний дім і
от це має значення для людей і це може
бути сприйнято
належним чином
На жаль я так розумію що
ну це в принципі
Напевно очікувано що з плином часу
цей градус емоції він буде спадати тому
що люди втомлюються І звісно що через
рік після того як весь світ живе з
розумінням що Росія напала на Україну і
росіяни вбивають воно воно просто вже
е-е ну як замилюється І звісно що
спочатку
в- вони прийняли рішення абсолютно
адекватне про українське Ми з самого
першого дня
Олімпійська
олімпійські там чемпіони олімпійські
призери
не будемо
згадувати представника тодішнього
керівника національного комітету пана
Бубки тому що з мого погляду він себе
некоректно і неправильно повів але всі
інші долучилися до
збору підписів до
флешмобів щодо того що росіяни не можуть
бути лученими до міжнародного спорту в
цей момент Тим паче що вони вже вкотре
порушують олімпійське перемир'я і саме в
період проведення олімпіад нападають на
суверенні держави такі як України так і
такі як Грузія Україна вже не перший раз
Ось і вони прийняли абсолютно адекватне
рішення через рік
Росія працювала звісно тому що ці от
доповідачі від ООН вони не взялися Там
просто так Я впевнений про які
постійно заявляє пан Бах з приводу того
що Ось там
є певна дискримінація за
паспортом тому що є там представники
доповідачів від ООН які
зробили свої відповідні заяви тобто Я
впевнений що ці люди працювали на
російську федерацію з за їх замовленням
були оці от е-е доповідачі зі своїми
доповідями представлені на на тих
майданчиках про які озвучують
озвучував пан Бах і ми маємо результат
тобто Звісно що Росія не сиділа просто
так
і вона працювала для того щоб
вирішити це питання тому що ще раз
повторюся для неї це вкрай важливий
майданчик для просування своєї
пропаганди і вкрай важливий інструмент
який важіль Яке Яка вона постійно
використовує не грибовище абсолютно
іншим а ми судячи з того як як я бачив
цю інформацію
сиділи і думали що так буде постійно і
нам не треба особливо нічого робити тому
що всі з нами солідарні і Всі розуміють
Хто в цій війні агресора А хто жертва А
ось Ну от Ми отримали результат 28
березня особисто ви хотіли б щоб
українські спортсмени все-таки поїхали
на олімпіаду однозначно Я впевнений що
ну для кожного повірте мені для кожного
я сам спортсмен для кожного спортсмена
Олімпійські ігри це найважливіший старт
в житті і кожен спортсмен хоче потрапити
на Олі і кожен кожен спортсмен хоче
виступити представити свою державу і
кожен спортсмен мріє про те щоб здобути
олімпійську медаль я вам 100% говорю Я
впевнений що наші спортсмени повинні
бути на олімпіаді підіймати український
прапор а росіяни повинні сидіти вдома з
білорусами Ось на жаль ситуація
абсолютно
повернулася догори дригом і наразі є
перспектива Що росіяни можуть бути на
цих змаганнях А українці будуть сидіти
вдома хоча ще нещодавно перспектива була
абсолютно інакше
Скажіть будь ласка Чи плануєте ви брати
участь в олімпіаді в Парижі
для того щоб обрати участь в Олімпії
треба на неї відібратися в нашому виді
спорту тому я планував брати участь в
відбірковому Чемпіонаті світу який
має бути в вересні місяці цього року і
там поборотися за здобуття ліцензії Якщо
б я
її там здобув то звісно продовжував
підготовку до олімпіади яка буде в
Парижі Дякую вам за цю розмову дякую вам